I'm Sally Lockwood and on this Sky News
Daily we're taking a look at this guy
good morning ladies and gentlemen this
is your Governor speaking today's
training Evolution dog fighting taking
on the corporate media The Rules of
Engagement are as follows number one
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis cast
himself as Maverick in a Top Gun
inspired campaign advert last year
does it say that in the bill I'm asking
you to tell me what's in the bill it was
pretty cheesy and was quickly pulled but
the 44 year old Republican is no
stranger to eye-catching ads to get his
messages across we fight the woke in the
legislature we fight the woke and the
corporations we fight the woke into
schools we never ever surrender to the
woke mob we have made Florida the state
where woke goes to die thank you so much
his aim to become America's next
president
so who is Ronda santis and crucially can
he beat Donald Trump to win the
Republican nomination our U.S
correspondent Mark Stone joins me from
Florida there too is Kirby Wilson who's
the state government reporter for the
Tampa Bay Times
Mark you know for many Rhonda santis is
the name that has stood out as the Trump
alternative for Republicans what are you
hearing from voters in Florida if you
look at the polls his approval rating
compared to Trump is nothing uh I mean
he's ahead of the the rest of the pack
but Trump is is way uh far ahead and
seems to continue to own the Republican
party but if there is someone that Trump
is worried about uh then it is Rhonda
Santos he won the governorship down in
Florida first time round by really not
very much and yet last year he won it by
a landslide a lot of that people say is
thanks to the platform that Donald Trump
gave him and yet the two have now fallen
out an awful lot in terms of his chances
I've heard this a lot that he's Trump
without the chaos so therefore can he
perhaps deliver in a way that Trump was
not always able to and that makes him
either a very exciting candidate or a
very scary one depending on your your
Viewpoint Kirby you've met Rhonda Santos
a number of times how do you think he's
going to Fair against his Florida
neighbor Donald Trump I wouldn't count
him out the polls are what they are
Trump is up by 30 plus points um but
there hasn't been a vote cast and there
won't be for six months DeSantis is
sitting on some 80 million dollars just
left over from his last election that he
can use for his presidential run using
some Financial chicanery that the U.S
campaign Finance law allows and he has
widespread name recognition a lot of
those in the donor class like Mark
alluded to are sick of the Trump chaos
Factor are attracted to somebody like
DeSantis who has a tiny tiny Inner
Circle that never leaks to the Press
doesn't backstab each other like the way
that Trump's Inner Circle does what else
do we know about him mark his backstory
is is fascinating his education was
about as establishment as it gets he ivy
league I mean he was at Yale and then
Harvard that's like being at Oxford and
then Cambridge I mean he did both he was
the captain of the baseball team at Yale
that's a big deal uh in America he went
on to join the Navy he was a lawyer in
the military he served in Guantanamo Bay
at a time which he doesn't talk about
much he was in Iraq as well
um and not just in Iraq he served as a
lawyer with the Navy Seals in Fallujah
in anbar Province the very most
dangerous part of Iraq in 2004 2005. he
was the guy who would be on those
operations telling the Navy Seals you
can engage here you can shoot that
person but you can't shoot that person
so he's got a a background which makes
him very attractive sort of action man
for those that like that sort of thing
he's had some very interesting campaign
videos hasn't he Kirby and certainly
there was a pretty powerful one
featuring his wife that made quite a
difference for him when he was running
for governor of Florida just like in the
2024 presidential race uh DeSantis is
coming came into the 2018 race for
governor as a pretty substantial
Underdog to a very well-funded establish
backed candidates so DeSantis is sort of
having to make a similar political
comeback and his the main tool in his
toolbox initially was that endorsement
from president Trump that Mark alluded
to earlier and the way that he sort of
made his name with voters in that race
was by cutting an ad in which his wife
uh sort of in a tongue-in-cheek way says
you know a lot of people think Ron is
all about Donald Trump but uh he's
there's really so much more to him
everyone knows my husband Ron DeSantis
is endorsed by President Trump but he's
also an amazing dad cuts to him playing
with his kids and he's teaching his
young kid to build a wall
then Mr Trump said you're fired I love
that part he's teaching math he's
reading and the Trump make America a
great again sign people say Ron's all
Trump but he is so much more big league
so good I just thought you should know
Ron DeSantis for governor so he's sort
of playing off of this idea that he's
all about Trump in a sort of self-aware
way and there aren't a lot of times
where uh where where Rhonda Sands is a
super funny guy or very self-aware guy
really
um but in these ads uh he was a little
more human and it'll be interesting to
see if he Taps more into that as he runs
for president certainly Those ads caught
Donald Trump's eye and won his
endorsement before but they're now
opponents they're now adversaries Mark
um how is that going down in Florida
who's more popular de Santa's came up
with a tagline make America Florida
which it was a neat play on on on the
tag of his of his old fan turned foe
Donald Trump Donald Trump was all about
make America great again well now it's
about make America Florida what DeSantis
is trying to do is throw forward he's
got these policies in place in Florida
and he's saying look the rest of America
can be like Florida like it or not um
and you know there's no question I mean
he won by a landslide here people in
Florida like Kim a majority of people
like his policies like this idea of of
going back to a pure time you know the
vibe is that America has lost its way
and needs to return to its traditional
conservative values and in Ron desantes
um they are finding those values are
being protected I'm in Miami now but we
drove down from um Daytona Beach further
up the coast which is in his in
desantis's Old
um congressional district where he first
started out as a as a politician and we
went to a diner The Starlight Diner
which is a bit of an institution in um
in Daytona at Bay um it's cliched you
may you might say going to a diner in in
Florida but you know you get you get a
great range of views you only have to to
prod a little at the diners there as
they eat their biscuits and gravy um
which many of you won't know about but
not my my thing I really didn't find
that everyone loved him you know I was
really struck at the first person we
spoke to had a real problem with this
idea of a war on woke that desantes
places front and center and and this guy
was like look I'm I'm happy to be woke
I'm a Floridian but I I see wokery as
about an Awakening an Awakening to the
way life is now
um life isn't like it was in the 50s and
people are should be represented in all
their their Shades in their sexuality
whatever they want to be but then at the
next door table I put this slogan make
America Florida again
um to an elderly white woman and she was
absolutely like yeah why not absolutely
fantastic Florida is fantastic I'm with
you on the biscuits and gravy by the way
not my back biscuits and gravy what do
you think Kirby well they're different
biscuits over here I need to note that
it's like having scones uh with great
exactly and then don't get me started on
grits but anyway sorry we digress
foreign
policies Kirby is Rhonda Santos is
certainly you know drawn his political
dividing lines tell us about how his
politics made a difference during covid
in in setting him apart from other state
Governors the pandemic was really
desantis's coming out party in a lot of
ways when the first cases were reported
in Florida interestingly he reacted like
a lot of other governors in the country
and he ordered businesses and schools uh
restaurants bars gyms shut down for
in-person service everything was virtual
we were basically on lockdown for a
couple months very little was open
unemployment soared all the things that
I think are would be horrifying to him
today he did
um but he opened a lot faster than other
states as cases were soaring in the
summer of 2020 he continued with the
state's reopening plan and by September
2020 everything was open full lease kids
were back in schools all the those
businesses were reopened and they never
closed again and not only did they not
close but a lot of tools that other
states had in their bag to deal with the
pandemic local mask mandates Statewide
Mass mandates local vaccine requirements
for businesses
um you know things like that he banned
local municipalities are not allowed to
issue Mass mandates under Florida law
now nobody in this no business in the
state can say you must be vaccinated in
order to enter the premises not allowed
under Florida law all of that is due to
Governor desantis's pushing and since
then he's also voiced a great deal of
skepticism about the safety and efficacy
of the MRNA covid vaccines so all of
that really gave him this unbelievable
calling card with the Republican voter
and the GOP base not just in Florida but
across the country people saw how open
Florida was and they came here to to
visit and in a lot of cases to move
because it was a drag to be locked
inside your house if you were living in
New York or California or Illinois on
the lockdowns I think the awkward
reality well the awkward Truth for those
who did you know most of the world that
did opt for shutting down is that the
evidence is suggesting and it's still
being collated I think but the evidence
is suggesting that Florida's death rate
when you take into account demographics
ages and all of that Florida's death
rate actually was no worse in fact was
better than the death rate in places
like New York and New Jersey where they
did lock down so he feels Vindicated
there he feels that his Hardline stance
um and saying you know what we're not
going to lock down because we believe
that it's better to keep the schools
open to keep people in work he took that
hard line stance and you know the
statistics appear to be showing that he
was right and he will run with that and
since then many say you know he's used
Florida is a petri dish for very
right-wing policies Kirby you know he's
restricted lgbtq rights curbed trans
rights banned abortions after six weeks
how has all that gone down in Florida
well if you judge by Electric election
results it's gone down swimmingly for
him he won a historic Landslide
re-election just seven months ago but
he's he's doubled down on on that slate
of policies even since then obviously
the six-week abortion bill was not in
effect when voters went to the polls in
November that particular policy I think
carries real electoral risk that is a
very extreme piece of legislation most
people don't know they're pregnant at
that point and banning abortion at that
point is uh basically it's tantamount to
an all-out ban
um on on the procedure as far as the
transgender rights yes he's restricted
the rights of not just kids to gain
access to a gender transition or gender
affirming care that kind of treatment
but but adults his administration has
cut Government funding for people that
were on government Health Care getting
access to that kind of treatment for
listeners who aren't aware Rhonda Santos
has also expanded capital punishment in
Florida people can also carry a
concealed firearm in the state now
without a permit Mark how much do you
think that these red meat conservative
policies are aimed at people in Florida
or is it showcasing Ronda Santa's
politics to Republicans Nationwide the
abortion issue aside he believes that
there is a majority of Voters in the
country that these policies will really
resonate with and I think perhaps the
most tangible one certainly the one
that's got so many headlines is this
book ban in Florida and the headline I
have to say is a bit misleading he is
not Banning books in Florida what he is
doing is restricting access to certain
books so he is Banning books that aren't
actually we're never actually available
in schools he's saying that such and
such a book shouldn't be available in
school there was one book um called
queer agenda queer that he was claiming
was available in in schools and actually
there's no evidence to suggest that
across the country this book was
available in schools but even if it was
those who believe that sort of book
should be in schools argue that we don't
live in the 1950s anymore we live in a a
time where teenagers
um are going I have questions that they
need answered and books like these are
educational so say those who think they
are they should be available there was
another example of a book for five to
six-year-olds in which two dads get
married or two male penguins have a you
know a particular friendship you know
these are books to introduce young
people uh to different ideas the
different realities of today now whether
or not they should be available in
schools or not clearly open to to heated
debates but but he has made a stance and
taken a stance that they shouldn't be
available to certain age groups and he
believes that across the country that
message that Paul policy will resonate
Kirby this is all of course linked to
Rhonda santis Rao with Disney he's
picked a fight with Disney which is a
high stakes move for any governor and it
and it's all over these issues of gender
and sexuality Governor DeSantis
supported a bill called the parental
rights and Education Act which a lot of
our opponents do it have deemed the
don't say gay bill which is a clever
slogans catchy
um but what the bill did was it
restricted education on gender and
sexuality in grades kindergarten through
third so it said that in grades K
through three you know we're talking
eight-year-olds a lot of its opponents
thought why are we singling out these
issues
so Disney was one of the opponents of
those bills it's past CEO Bob chapek
came out and said we will work toward
this bill's repeal after DeSantis signed
it Governor DeSantis took major
exception to the idea that Disney would
stake its sort of
corporate capital on repealing a bill
that the legislature passed and so the
argument that I would hear from
lawmakers was if Disney was advocating
against a bill that directed Disney and
its ability to put out movies or invite
people to its theme parks that would be
one thing but they're weighing in on a
social issue and that is inappropriate
so the legislature at sort of desantis's
behest cracked down on Disney by passing
a law that stripped Disney of a lot of
the special government privileges that
it had gotten 50 years ago when Walt
Disney first built uh the theme parks
here in Florida not to get two in the
weeds but they're suing each other uh
now and it all started with this sort of
I think kind of
overblown fight I will say as an
addendum to all that since that bill
passed the don't say gay bill
um it has been expanded into older
grades and so I think that adds fuel to
the critics who said it wasn't just
young kids that you wanted to not be
taught about gender identity and sexual
orientation it's all kids and that is
basically what we've seen and Mark this
fight with Disney is all part of Rhonda
Santos big war on woke how how is that
working out for him how's it going down
with voters back to my Diner very mixed
even among Floridians on the face of it
people who aren't
you know have got more important things
in their own lives to worry about they
see this war on woke and they think yeah
you know quite right but but actually
when you drill down as as Kirby just did
you you realize that that messages are
mixed and the common sense seems to have
got lost uh in all of it and and I that
that's certainly my sort of takeaway
Mark Kirby before we weigh up whether
Ronda Santa has got what it takes to
take the White House the big question
can he beat Donald Trump to win the
Republican nomination Mark your thoughts
first it's very bad idea to make
predictions so uh this may not date well
but my hunch is no I mean imagine the TV
debate the debate between DeSantis and
and Trump I I think Trump would do
better but uh come back to me in a few
months and you can uh we can see if I'm
spectacularly wrong Kirby what's your
take on it I'm getting 2016 vibes from
this race already uh if if it was just
Trump versus DeSantis I think we would
have a real question on our hands but
with so many other candidates entering
the race they seem to not believe
DeSantis has the juice and as someone
who's watched the scientists closely for
a long time he has not ever really been
punched in the mouth Republicans have
run Florida for two decades he has he
walked in and assumed control of a
well-oiled machine that was geared to
pass his kind of policies but a
presidential race has a lot of factors
that he can't control Kobe does Wonder
santis have a likability issue
absolutely the Republican voters are mad
they don't want somebody who's likable
they want somebody who's mad at the same
stuff they're mad at Trump is mad at the
stuff that they're mad at and so is
DeSantis on Tuesday nights we saw Donald
Trump appear virtually a Manhattan Court
over alleged hush money payments and the
trial date for that is March next year
right in the middle of primary season
Mark how worrying is that for Donald
Trump and do you think he feels
threatened any in any way by Ron
DeSantis I just wonder if a majority of
people in this country are fed up with
the chaos that surrounds everything
Donald Trump seems to do are fed up with
the negativity uh the anger that seems
to surround so many of the Republican
Party candidates and whether they are
they may well be deeply conservative but
they want something that's a little bit
more hopeful a little bit more Unity a
little bit more bringing America America
together again and if that's the case
Trump de Santa's neither of them is your
man hypothetically Kirby if Ronda santis
does beat Donald Trump if he did beat
Joe Biden what would it mean for the
American people it would mean that there
is a highly competent deeply deeply
conservative man in the white house
which arguably we have not seen since
Ronald Reagan and I I don't mean to take
a partisan shot at president Trump by
saying he wasn't competent but he really
didn't enact many of the policies that
Republicans would have liked to see
um when he was in the White House
DeSantis poses a real threat to that
kind of uh Paradigm in America he's
competent he is smart uh and he is he's
a True Believer his shortcomings however
are that he doesn't have people skills
and he has no interest or ability in
doing anything other than what he is
interested in when Congress is so
divided you can't just say I would like
this law passed please and then it
passes that works in Tallahassee Florida
where everyone is a republican it
doesn't work in Washington DC
my thanks to Mark Stone and Kirby Wilson
and to you for listening to the Sky News
Daily with me Sally Lockwood you can
watch Mark's report on the Sky News
YouTube channel this episode was
produced by Annie Joyce our editor is
Philly Beaumont